in Florida new emergency orders and
curfews have been expanded to slow the
spread the state is now up to nearly
160,000 cases many beaches are closing
ahead of this July 4th holiday weekend
in some areas are running low on
coronavirus tests our lead national
correspondent that's David Beck now is
in Miami with more on this story David
always good to see you what are the new
rules good morning my friend they're not
just telling you to wear masks here
suggesting it saying it's a good idea
they're done with that they're now
requiring it in fact the mayor here in
miami-dade County the most populated
county in the state of Florida said you
are now required to wear it outdoors
even if you can socially distance even
if the next person is 20 feet from you
you are required to wear it and if you
don't we may find you
Andrew Chun is a code compliance officer
in Miami Beach he spent more time
yesterday educating people on why they
should be wearing a mask and telling
them it is a requirement here what are
you hearing from the non-compliant
people some people will walk away from
you while I'm trying to talk to them and
I tried to make a situation into Earth
or instigate anything more has the city
written anyone a fine as today not to my
knowledge no
my body my choice is what dozens of
maskless protesters chanted as they
marched to the streets of Sanford
Florida outside of Orlando yesterday
there been studies suggesting that if
95% of Americans wear face masks that
could save over 30,000 lives by this
fall dr. Howard Koh is the former
assistant secretary for health in the
Obama administration he says he hopes to
see a nationwide mask mandate to slow
down the deadly virus that is far
outpacing efforts to contain it right
now
we stopped by Jackson Memorial Miami's
largest hospital yesterday after getting
word that they are scaling back elective
surgeries and other procedures dr. Lilly
Lee is medical director in the emergency
room how does it help you to put a pause
on elective procedures right now well
it's gonna release some of the resources
that are being focused on elective
surgery onto the patient that are coming
in that requires hospitalization so you
can take some of the staff who would be
working on those elective procedures and
move them into the emergency department
for other areas absolutely there are
three exceptions to the mandate now for
you to wear masks outside here in
miami-dade County number one if you're
jogging number two if you have a
respiratory condition that makes it hard
for you to breathe with this on and
lastly for children under the age of two
they do not have to wear masks Anthony
David beg no thanks David